good morning and welcome to sky news
breakfast thank you for joining us
free rapid testing will be made
available to families with children in
school or college under plans for
schools to reopen in england next week
secondary and college pupils will have
the lateral flow test twice weekly the
kits will be available to collect from
more than 500 locations
across the country anisha that reports
we've all heard the tales and tantrums
of homeschooling
but parents will soon be faced with a
new role
the government's advising all households
with school-age children
to carry out rapid covert tests twice a
week
parents just jorton mandeep welcome the
move
i don't have an issue with it in terms
of how
often they have to do the testing
because i think
it's it's not a big ask if you compare
it to
the number of people's lives that have
been
affected the number of people that have
lost their lives
to ask people to do a simple test it's
not it's not a big deal
rapid testing at home means positive
cases can isolate quickly
this could be the difference between a
class being sent home because of an
outbreak
or children being able to stay in school
from the 8th of march free rapid test
kits will be available to collect
from over 500 locations nhs england
stresses the effort to detect
asymptomatic cases well i'm sure there
will be a lot of assistance for schools
and children
to do tests testing has expanded greatly
over the last few months
and it's one important component of our
battle against coronavirus
and it's a battle which school leaders
have been fighting for almost a year
anything that encourages a joint effort
in securing the health the public health
of all of our
children going into schools and for
teachers i think yeah
absolutely it will encourage teachers to
feel far safer coming into school
[Music]
as home schooling soon comes to an end
parents will be swapping mark aboard
pens for lateral flow tests
in the next stage of community testing
anisha sethi
sky news
let's take a look at the latest
coronavirus figures now for the uk
and 7434 new confirmed cases of covid19
were recorded
in the most recent 24-hour period that's
the lowest number
for around five months a further 290
people have died within 28 days of
testing positive
that brings the uk total to 122
705 and 19.6 million first doses of the
vaccine have been administered
a 5 billion pound scheme to help pubs
restaurants and retailers hit hardest by
the lockdown
is set to be revealed by the chancellor
in wednesday's budget
non-essential shops in england and
hospitality venues will be able to apply
for
so-called restart grants our political
correspondent rob powell joins us now
from westminster
and robert just how will this uh much
needed help
for the high street actually work so the
grants will be up to 18 000 pounds per
firm jillian
they'll be available to shops
restaurants pubs but also gyms hair
salons
delivered through local authorities in
england although there'll be extra money
going to the devolved nations as well
now i think that will be welcomed by
business
i expect what they will want to hear
from the chancellor rishi sunak who you
can see there
on wednesday though is news about things
like the furlough scheme that's been
supporting jobs for
what the past nine ten months or so and
also business rates too
i think those will be the giveaways but
there's also likely to be
the clearest indication yet of how the
chancellor plans to plug the giant hole
in the nation's finances caused by the
coronavirus
bailout really we may not get immediate
huge tax rises
but there may well be a roadmap and an
indication of where they will come
further down the track we've heard all
about corporation tax
the last few days taxes on businesses
going up
as well the sunday times eye-catchingly
reporting today plans
to potentially freeze the amount of
money that you earn
before you start paying tax on income
tax so that will
affect far more people i think though
a lot of these uh expected
pre-budget uh leaks um if you like
should be treated with um a degree of
caution right the way through the
pandemic the treasury has been pretty
adept
uh managing their message and
occasionally uh managing to make their
actual policy announcements feel more
generous or less stringent
than they might do otherwise and i think
the chancellor will be acutely aware
that as much as there is an economic
problem to fix on wednesday he
also needs to look after the politics
and his political image because a lot of
backbenchers
who uh look very favorably on rishi
sunak they want to see him come out of
this as the low tax
low tax chancellor the challenge is how
you how do you maintain your image as a
low tax chancellor
while also putting up taxes president
trump will make his first public
appearance since leaving the white house
later today when he speaks at a
conference for american conservatives
although he remains banned by social
media the former u.s leader still
dominates republican politics organizers
say
excuse me they believe mr trump has
scores to settle
this evening mr bunkel has this report
from orlando
in florida
there is a conference center in downtown
orlando this weekend
where donald trump still rules america
he might have lost the election
but not the faith of his party all my
friends still want trump things and
actually uh
the hat that i need i got the one that
says 20 20 on it but i need the one that
says 2024 on it
we're ready for president trump to come
back we want to see our president
and i say our president meaning the
people's president
trump the florida local will speak here
on sunday
his first public appearance since
leaving the white house banned from
twitter still
he's bound to have a lot to say i think
he wants to say the things
that will make twitter the most anxious
with him
which is maybe settling some scores and
taking people on who have said some
rather unkind things to him
but by the same token um i think he's
going to talk about
this coalition that he built i mean it's
a coalition unlike the republican
party's ever seen before
you would like donald trump to run again
in 24 would you oh absolutely absolutely
i think pretty much everybody here does
do you think he will i'm hoping so i
think what he's going to do though is i
don't think he'll commit tomorrow
if you've read his book the art of the
deal he likes to keep options open
typically political parties reinvent
themselves after an election loss
not the republicans if anything nothing
has changed
they believe in trump and want more of
the same no doubt who the
star attraction is here and there's no
doubt who
they want to run in 2024 but
what is interesting is not just who is
here but who is not here
big figures within the republican party
like mitt romney
like the former u.s vice president mike
pence
the former u.s ambassador the united
nations nikki haley
all of them have their own ambitions and
any of them
could be influential come 2024.
if a week is a long time in politics
then four years
is a lifetime but if donald trump wants
to run again
right now there doesn't seem to be much
to stop him
bunker sky news orlando
it's been revealed one school girl
managed to escape
after gunman abducted her classmates in
nigeria
317 girls are still missing after being
snatched in the second school attack in
little over a week
parents and teachers are calling on the
government to do more to protect
students as emma birchley reports
when bandits came to her room masada
umar hid silently beneath her bed
but she was the only one to escape the
raid on her school in zamfara state in
northern nigeria
three hundred and seventeen other girls
were kidnapped
at gunpoint
one of the bandits drew the hands of the
house captain and slapped her and asked
her to go
then the bandits asked everybody to go
inside the hostel and they chased some
people and asked them to leave
and then they walked towards our own
room and knocked on the door
i was coming out from the door and i met
somebody but ran back and hid under my
bed
this is just the latest attack on
nigeria's academies and their students
they're then used in warfare or traded
for profit by military groups
it's an all too common problem in a
country gripped by civil war
these boys 47 of them the latest to be
released for the parents reunited with
their children
relief but the boy's eyes tell a story
of two weeks of trauma
not knowing if they'd see their families
again
many parents are now too scared to send
their children to school
blaming their government for failing to
protect them
one father also a teacher has lost two
children
and fears they may not come home you
have nothing to say
than to pray to god
but we are not hundred percent sure that
they can bring back our jails in time
and we are not hundred percent sure that
even if they bring them back they will
not come back with some angels in their
body
and a return to school terrifies
missouri too
i'm scared of going back to school
because of what happened
it really got me scared but i will go
back if the government tackle
insecurity police and military continue
to search for masada's school friends
she can only hope it's successful emma
birchley sky news
now the chancellor will deliver his
budget on wednesday
as well as a cash injection to help the
high street he's expected to reveal
a mortgage guarantee scheme for
first-time buyers
joining me now is alfie sterling the
director of research and chief economist
at the new economics foundation good
morning to you and
much being made of this 5 billion pounds
injection that's really going to be the
headliner isn't it
i think it may be although of course
what happens to the furlough scheme and
confirmation that the furlough scheme is
extended
may well end up being the single most
important announcement
on the day but certainly 5 billion
pounds for the high street
will be really important especially if
it doesn't come with too many conditions
or stipulations that the key question i
think over the rest of this year will be
how much has
uh household spending changed
permanently how much people shifted
towards
online shopping and not going
hospitality near their offices
and what impact that might have for the
high street longer term
there's also this line about the um
accidental
savers that people have saved a lot a
lot of money through lockdown
and we've heard various commentators
saying that really spending
our way out of economic recession is is
the way to go and that's what will
happen what are your thoughts on that
so i think the overall story here is
that the recovery if government doesn't
do anything
will be very k-shaped so with one part
the population really recovering fast
and rapidly that's the people who have
been fortunate enough to keep their jobs
to actually build up
savings and disposable income because
the sectors of the economy they normally
spend in
non-essential retail hospitality uh
tourism
they've all been locked down so they've
got a lot of pent-up spending if you
like but the other part of the
population
20-25 percent is what the current
numbers look like i've seen a real hit
to income and of course these are the
people
working in those sectors that have been
shut down and they're going to they're
at risk now of a
really really rough time unless
government puts in place support that
has been needed now for 12 months you
know
thinking about the self-employed falling
through the cracks people on
universal credit because they fell
through them the furlough scheme
um not having the support they need and
that's it's a big divergence now in this
k-shaped
recovery that is the danger going
forward and this mortgage uh
guarantee scheme uh 95 mortgages for
first-time
buyers um is that entirely new isn't
that sort of
help to buy in a different by different
name
it is it's um you know continuation of
the sorts of policies we've seen now for
quite a while i mean i do find this
really quite
um concerning actually i mean one one
reason it's concerning is because
we seem to have a culture in this
country where public debt is somehow
incredibly
toxic or bad even when government
has very low interest rates and savings
are desperate to lend government
and yet private debt in the form of you
know getting first-time buyers people
with not
um often a very large deposit to borrow
more and more to keep the housing market
flowing to keep the economy moving
is somehow good and progressive and it's
just not the case it's a real risk
um to the economy but the second reason
um is that actually these sorts of
products is these
these financial products to increase
demand for housing from ever increasing
portions of the population
by extending credit all they do in the
long run is increase house prices
unless you can actually do something
about the supply of housing and so
very sadly it won't be first-time buyers
and those that are just out of reach of
housing that will benefit in the long
run it's those who already have property
who'll benefit from the increase
in house prices and i think that could
be a real problem uh if we wanted to
address what i described earlier as
k-shaped recovery with
a portion of the population missing out
for the billions of pounds that uh has
so far been spent we are going to have
to
pay back what are we looking at in terms
of of taxes
so the interesting thing is actually
that the last this pandemic has exposed
um two uh really important truths one is
that when you're in a crisis
there isn't really a constraint on
government borrowing and that's because
all the savings in the population that
get built built up by people who are
doing okay
they need to go somewhere they need to
go somewhere safe and in a recession
government is one of the few
safe places at the same time the central
bank can also guarantee
um government debt so in a crisis like
this actually government can borrow very
cheaply and in fact we've had negative
interest rates
had interest rates well below inflation
effectively government being paid
to borrow that money doesn't need to be
paid back
but what does need to happen um is that
through time we can't maintain this
level
of borrowing and actually the second
really important lesson from this
pandemic
is that our public services were far too
brittle and vulnerable going into this
crisis you know i'm thinking
not enough capacity in the nhs a safety
net that was one of the weakest in
europe until we temporarily brought in
the furlough scheme and that does need
to be corrected and restored and to do
that to have you know
permanently stronger uh public insurance
we do need higher taxes for the long
term and that's that's the key there and
i think therefore
you know moving towards higher taxes at
this budget and making those
announcements for the future would be a
positive
step higher taxes for the long term
although sterling thank you very much
for sharing your analysis with us thank
you
many thanks okay isabel's here now with
the weather is it going to be lovely
enough for you to
have your run i i am going to run
as soon as i get home quarter past nine
um
because it's lovely i mean it will be a
bit murky first thing and it will be for
many across central and eastern parts
but then the sun will return
there'll be a lovely sunday once again
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
not quite as sunny from the start though
there will be more mr low cloud around
that will gradually
uh burn back to the east coast the cloud
across scotland and northern ireland
should break nicely too
and as i said it's an improving picture
for many of us so yes it's quite chilly
out there where we've had the breaks in
the cloud overnight for example through
the heart of the country
it's about minus two locally but it will
get up to around 10 to 13 degrees today
with sunshine that's just above average
chile on exposed coast where it could
well turn rather more misty and murky
through the course of the afternoon the
southeastern coast an example maybe
southeast ireland but otherwise
it's a lovely end to the day and then
you'll find that tonight there are
changes the north turning frosty
with some patchy fog but southern and
eastern air is increasingly murky again
with miss low cloud and fog that will
push right across
southern britain and up into southern
ireland with that quite brisk east wind
it will burn back to the coast for many
but it could
persist through the midlands tomorrow
parts of lincolnshire as well so here
maybe six seven degrees at best
elsewhere though again plenty of blue
sky highs around 10
to 13 degrees
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
two holocaust survivors are calling on
boris johnson to meet them ahead of a
commons vote which could force the
government to take a tougher stance
on china's treatment of uyghur muslims
the so-called
genocide amendment would allow the uk to
limit trade with any country
committing genocide so far the
government has opposed it
let's speak to uh dorit oliver wolfe who
joins me now good
morning to you um what exactly are you
calling
on the uk government to do in terms of
the weaker situation well good morning
and i'm calling on the government
first of all it would be wonderful if
boris johnson
would meet up with me and my colleague
ruth
but it is not against china
i have to point out because i love the
chinese culture and i love the chinese
people i love everybody
but i'm completely against genocide
as a holocaust survivor i know how it is
to be taken away your freedom your
dignity
and to be waiting for the next person
who is going to kill you
gas chambers etc and now it's happening
again
and i am asking
for the government to
accept that this is a genocide it is not
anybody's imagination it is happening
now it was not yesterday
it is happening now look at those people
i mean it is just a crime and we are
joining in accepting a crime
that is killing people everybody is
entitled to be free
i mean how can we stand by
and enjoy television and everything
every daily
enjoyment that we are still alive even
though that we have got this coronal
virus epidemic we are still free
but these people have to be free there
is no
question it is wrong
and the british government
i mean we should be the beacon of
democracy
and we should stand by it we should not
allow
other people to treat humans
inhumanly and that's as strongly as you
feel
about this that the government is is
standing by
while the the uyghur muslims are being
persecuted
in china is that your your belief yes
and of course they should put the
the amendment through that they accept
it because
there it is still not accepted
and we cannot accept to have a
government
that is taking it just yes we'll do
something
it is now the time to definitely do
something about it
and beat vigor people or any other
oppressed people
it is just wrong and please please if
only
if boris johnson is watching if he gets
up this early of course
if he could just grant ruth and i
to talk to him about it it would be
absolutely amazing
and also please anybody who is watching
could you
join to sign the petition believe it or
not
we reached 43 000
it's amazing and it only shows that
people do care
so please help us and the british
government should
change the amendment please as a
holocaust
survivor what would you say to
boris johnson how would you be able to
express
what it's like to be in those
circumstances
and the need for international help
first of all i would tell boris johnson
if he not wants to know
what the suffering is all about to read
my memoirs from yellowstart or pop star
and i would even sign it for him but
that explains
how the jews were treated during the
holocaust
and i would just talk to him because i
met him once and he's very charming
just before he became prime minister but
i would just ask him to
join and to do something about it
because
it is commerce and money is of course
very important we all have to live
but human life is more important and
what is the price of a vigor what is the
price of any of us
what price do you put on each head
it has to be stopped that's what i would
ask him to do
how confident are you of a meeting or
even a conversation
with the prime minister before the
amendment on
tuesday well if he can listen to it
if it's not stopped by the secretaries
and the private the people who are
around him if it's really passed on to
him
i'm quite sure he would say because he's
a very
compassionate and i had a journey with
him from eastbourne on the train
to london and we had a long talk and i
found him more
most humorous very funny and i think
that
whilst he's very very busy and you know
it is very he has a lot thrown onto him
corona virus brexit
but this is i want to appeal to him
to his human feelings as a human being
to another human being
to have compassion and understanding
that these are people
who haven't done anything wrong it is
just because perhaps they pray to their
god in a different way
than other people's pray everybody every
human being should have
freedom and right for life and living
and we cannot sit here
sipping our cappuccia you see
i can say that and think oh well it is
happening up
it's nothing to do with us everything
has to do with us
because it's if it hurts us it can be my
next-door neighbor tomorrow
it is just wrong and please please
think about it if you were in the same
position
if one of you family would be behind
bars
and their bodies used to body parts to
give away
and be killed and be
uh well just simply
taking away the freedom
it's wrong oliver wolfe
thank you very much for speaking with us
um
thank you very much for listening and i
hope you do something about it
thank you welcome back with us this
morning again to take us through the
newspapers the anthropologist mariana
hotter and the broadcaster
pete price welcome back to both your
final outing of the morning um
starting with the sunday telegraph and
uh mary ann you've had a look at this
story and it's the story on all of the
front pages
the budget and what we might expect uh
they're kicking off with a possible tax
on online deliveries
uh yeah so obviously there's been a
massive
windfall basically for all those online
companies
who when you're thinking about the big
ones like amazon
um you know their tax bills are small
anyway because they have teams and teams
of
lawyers and tax specialists work out the
most effective way of not paying
um tax that is i guess legal
uh so the question is obviously we're
looking at a high street that is is has
been tripled over the past 100 years
um past years sorry and
that you know we're possibly facing
hundreds of bankruptcies
um so what the the um
what the chancellor is probably going to
announce in the budget on wednesday
is um additional support for those
businesses to get
back um to a position where they can
open and thrive
over 2021 and get back on their feet um
so businesses should be able to claim up
to 18 000 pounds to get ready to trade
again
things like hairdressers gyms uh all the
non-essential shops that have been
closed for periods of months
um the they're also going to
now and the question is the way the
telegraph has framed it
is that this is kind of going to be
stealth taxes
but the bottom line is that um
there's a 43 billion pound shortfall in
the uk budget because
covid has been very very expensive now
obviously this is the rainy day for
which governments plan
but we also need to be on a strong
economic footing to kind of grow and
prosper for
moving forwards so um his suggestions
or what what's going to be proposed
probably on wednesday
is that they will be a freeze
effectively on the thresholds for
income tax i think that's the one that's
going to impact the most
people so for the next three years the
threshold where people start paying tax
so that's 12 and a half thousand pounds
and the threshold for people becoming
higher rate taxpayers so that's
currently 50 000 pounds
won't go up and so effectively that
means more people
as as as as wages rise with inflation
more people will fall into those
brackets so an extra
one and one and a half million people
will end up in the higher tax paying
bracket
by 2024 so he's not increasing income
tax he's freezing the thresholds which
is kind of a
kind of a different way of of bringing
more money
into the into the treasury um coffers
and allows allows the conservatives to
to say that they're sticking to their
pledge of not
not raising taxes pete let's have a look
at the uh sunday
mirror and we've seen haven't we that
the royals coming out and uh
you know giving their advice on
everybody taking up the vaccine we've
seen the queen
unprecedented message from the queen and
now kate and william taking on their
anti-vaxxers
i think it's essential um elton john and
michael caine have done a video
everybody's getting involved with it i
read in one of the sunday papers today
that 200
000 nhs and care workers haven't had the
job yet
now i think uh if i'm right and saying
if we didn't have vaccination
we'd still have polio which was
eradicated in this world
i think it's absolutely stupid i can't
understand their mentality
i think if you work in a care home and
you don't have the job i think that's
very unfair to all the patients and
people out there
i find it bizarre but also the internet
has got an
awful lot to answer for because without
the internet we wouldn't have had these
problems
there's these anti-vaxxers and they
really need help
because they've got problems having said
that there are many out there
that are just doing it for a laugh i
mean do we want to get out of lockdown
everybody watching now do we want to get
out of lockdown
do we want another lockdown in june
because we've got to have the
vaccination
sorry i'm getting upset it really really
annoys me
uh do you think that people should um
only be employed
in in the future if they're able to show
proof of having been vaccinated
would you go that far i would
i would absolutely especially within the
nhs and
within the care service absolutely there
are loved ones in those homes they need
protecting
absolutely to the sun
if they wanted to go sorry if they
wanted to go on holiday they'd get a
vaccination in a shot
if that got them away interesting
uh to the sun let's look at this story
that
some suggestion that teachers are
hatching a plan to
uh disrupt the return of students on the
march the 8th
oh that wasn't going to be a story that
i was going to talk about um
but i think that teachers are under
massive pressure um they're they're
facing
you know uncertainty in terms of what
the the situation is going to be when
they're back in front of
a group of students in busy secondary
schools particularly
they have to not only try and help their
students get
back up to speed they're also some of
the other stories in the in the papers
are saying that you know once kids go
back to school those
education professionals are going to see
the real impact psychological mental
health
impacts that have of
disproportionately affected kids coming
from poorer backgrounds as well
and the question is you know
do teachers feel safe standing at the
front of their classrooms and i think i
would certainly advocate that teachers
early years professionals should be in
one of the priority groups for
vaccination because
as soon as you've got a teacher who's
ill or you've got a lot of teaching
staff
who become ill or get positive covert
tests
then that knock on impact on the rest of
the the school ecosystem
and all the families who are affected by
children who then perhaps can't go to
school because they don't have teachers
or perhaps might have had close contact
with teachers
um because they were helping them with
work or what have you and they're having
to stay at home
then immediately we're all sort of back
to square one parents are having to stay
at home or perhaps curtail their work
and students just need to be able to get
on with learning to have those social
opportunities
to grow as people because otherwise the
impacts of covid are going to be felt
for more than a generation because we're
going to have
damaged young people who just can't
access the support they need
and teachers who are on the front line
so we
really need to rally around support
teachers listen to their concerns
and that is part of what pete was saying
that you know we're all having to pull
together to to get life back to normal
and support the people who need extra
support as much as possible
brilliant especially on a story that you
weren't thinking that you were going to
do
quite clearly have opinions on it um are
you going to talk about uh litter what
what's this story about
oh yeah i can talk about this as well
i think that one's peace yeah i think
the litter story is incredible they're
talking about finding people
for throwing litter out of cars this is
a pet hater mine
i'm from the old school when you put
your litter in your pocket you took it
home with you
i have actually and i'm not a fighter
but i i love an
argument but i've not tried to pete
no no no not a fighter a verbal fighter
fighter as in i've chased cars down
motorways that have thrown litter out
i am incensed but i don't know how
they're going to police it they're going
to do with cct camera because
i just think it's the most disgraceful
thing
i and the way i would punish them by the
way i'd go to their house
and empty bins of litter all over the
lounge all over the furniture the lot
yeah not obsessed at all but i do i do
share your concerns i mean with the
lockdown sort of doing
you know much more walking and running
outdoors the litter strewn
everywhere when you're outside of a car
you really do notice it don't you miriam
oh it's absolutely disgusting i i
couldn't believe it when i read this
story it costs
one billion pounds every year to clear
up the litter
that people chuck out of of cars
chuck out of their pockets onto our
street why tip that's
30 million tons of rubbish and
some people say well we need better
education campaigns but i
i agree with pete it's common sense yeah
don't
throw crap out of your windows
absolutely
well said now this is a really uh lovely
little story in the the sunday times
um who can tell us what pet flicks is
mary anne i think you've had a look at
this yes
um yeah this is this is kind of sweet
but hilarious and also slightly worrying
um there's a on-demand uh service
which you can pay a kind of monthly
charge for that should in principle help
relax your dog
and so you can pay a subscription for
them like you're paying um perhaps for
netflix you can pay for
pet flicks um and you get videos
of um basically like dog's eye view of
running through fields
watching birds so they can't actually do
the running through fields but they can
can look at it on the screen um virtual
dog walking what do you think of that
idea pete
i love it absolutely love it
it's crazy i mean the animals now you go
out for a walk and
everybody's got their dog and they've
all bought the dogs and by the way a
dog's for life
not for christmas marianne and pete
thank you so much for taking
us through the papers good to see you
take care have a great week